but what you know we are kind of getting
off we were talking about anti-fun i
really want to focus on this because
yes five days to an election yes i can't
believe it i i have to wonder if like
i'm this is this this next part is a
joke okay because i know people are
going to freak out
that a bunch of trump supporters dressed
up like antifa like this is how you get
trump elected in pa
i'm joking okay the point is though
donald trump
is going rally rally rally in
pennsylvania vote for me
and he's going suburban women love me
you have to love me i've done so much
it's it's actually funny
they criticize him for it but he's he's
half joking like he really does need
their vote
but he's just like you know hamming it
up but uh
so there's only so much rallies can do
you've got western
you've got western pennsylvania fracking
country joe biden sealed the deal on
that
when he was like yeah and he's like
we're going to transition out of oil yes
yes and then the moderator's like why
would you do that like almost like she
was faceplanting that he said it not
that he would actually want to do it
why would you say that exactly that's
what it sounded like to me
but how do you get eastern pennsylvania
right it's erupted in philadelphia three
nights in a row people are looting
you know five below walmart they're like
you see the video where the cars are
just like crashing at each other and
like tvs are flying through the air
it's like so they're in the parking lot
of the walmart and people are just
running away with stuff
and then like someone's got like a tv in
the middle of the road a car hits it it
just flips over the car and they're like
crashing into each other
it was nuts yeah and even a guy like
loaded up his truck full of looted
material
and then he got robbed for his for his
car full
of leads they're looting the looters
yeah and apparently they were shooting
each other too and fighting and fighting
over yeah
i think i think shelby and elijah her
you know were there with shots fired
and so you know it's just criminals
doing criminal stuff yo in dc
is it fed so that's federal right are
they sending out the feds taking care of
that dude if you get a
so uh activist organizations warn
protesters
you get arrested protesting in dc those
are federal charges they're very very
hard to beat
and the uh the penalties are severe
whereas
state city jurisdictions sometimes you
get a slap on the wrist not the feds
hey what what is the name of that legal
fund that's always bailing out those
antifa guys they were down on the scene
last night too and i
i think that's what happened they saw me
streaming the antifa guys
because i i was streaming the cops and
stuff but then i saw the legal aid
you know national lawyers guild that's
it national lawyers progressive
organizations they were on the ground
there and that's part of the
support ecosystem that enables people to
go to jail and
have lawyers and bail and that way they
can get arrested with impunity
you know i'll tell you what man during
occupy things were different
and it's a there's a weird authoritarian
switch that occurred
i remember i was on uh you know i can't
remember what street it was me like 12th
or something
i was it was in new york it was like the
lower east side and there was a national
lawyer's guild lawyer
who had just witnessed an arrest we were
standing on the sidewalk
and he starts cr i'm standing here on
the corner and he starts walking through
the crosswalk not jaywalking
and he's on his phone and he's looking
at cops are making an arrest and he
starts reporting to his colleagues and a
bunch of cops run up and grab him and
throw him against the car his phone goes
flying and i'm filming i'm like whoa
what the and then he's like what are you
doing i'm a lawyer i'm a lawyer and
they're like shut up
they cuff him they arrest him and then i
actually had a phone call like
what happened why did they arrest him
like he literally wasn't doing anything
man
it was it was a lawyer on this so i see
things like that i've seen things where
the national lawyers guild has done
good in stopping things like this but
something changed
and i remember when i was in boston it
was 2018 and there were there was there
was antifa
and there were right-wing protesters the
antifa guys had clubs they were wearing
black masks
full blackout gear with clubs and bats
and there was the national lawyers guild
standing at their side
and then across from them was a bunch of
guys with like pepe signs and shields
and i asked the national lawyers i was
like hey how come you guys are only on
one side
and they're like what do you mean and
i'm like why aren't you guys observing
for those guys
and they were like i don't understand
and i was like okay
and then i tweeted about it and then a
bunch of lefties they were like tim
poole's defending the fascists
and i'm like the national lawyers guild
said their mission was to observe the
police
not counter protests right i thought
they were there to make sure that people
were peacefully legally allowed to
protest
and that includes the left and the right
no it wasn't it was about supporting
progressive causes
and now that the conflict isn't about
police versus protester
it's like left and right tribe or
whatever national lawyers guild is
overtly tribalist
and will will not help you in defending
your rights
they won't like was anyone there when
you were getting attacked i need these
lg guys no nobody
they're not going to believe the police
were there because because i'd imagine
they're going to be like oh we're not
going to film this we don't observe this
because then we got to testify against
them
right there were a number of people
filming and taking pictures i haven't
seen any of them surfaced just yet and
i would like to see them i was standing
there surrounded by like 30 people just
like that that would probably be a good
pick i'd like to see it so
if you were that guy last night send it
out hit me up on twitter jackmurphylife
or on my youtube channel jack murphy
live thank you very much i'll see you
guys there as well excellent
so uh you think the riots are gonna well
so as i was saying about pennsylvania
i don't know exactly if you can turn a
city red
you know i don't i don't know what would
make something like that happen but i i
imagine
i don't know if you remember that video
where the christopher columbus statue
was getting attacked
and so all of these like middle-aged and
younger dudes like union guys came out
and surrounded it
and got physical like shoving antifa
some guys said bat some guys had guns
and they were like get out of here
then the city came and took the statue
away anyway i can only imagine the
like these are these are probably union
democrat guys in philadelphia 80
democrat city now they're taking your
statue down you tried to defend now
they're riding and it's not just
in like downtown i think they call it
center city it's spread around
all over the place and they were the the
videos are nuts i got to imagine
there's a certain part of these like
regular working-class union guys who are
democrats who are probably going i've
had i've had enough of this man
and i wonder if they're gonna it's gonna
it's gonna be a big push for trump
i mean they did make a big part up of
the nine million democrats of deplorable
voters in 2016.
i'm hoping that that trend is going to
continue it's very clear to see
that there you know the the republican
party is becoming sort of the party of
men
right and the democratic party is
becoming the party of women and
minorities
i got i got to stop you there though
there's something really interesting i
saw in
uh i was looking at early voting data in
um
i think it was michigan the uh most of
the votes that have come in so far early
in absentee
lean gop the the plurality is gp voters
and women nice that that was weird to me
i was like wait
wait the majority of returned ballots
and early voting
came from women and the majority and it
was a plurality was women
not a majority and then the plurality
was republicans meaning
there's an uptick in republican women
who are voting awesome and they're
helping get that push so that's
i've always said that it's the party of
masculine men and the women who love
them
right yeah yep yep that's so you got to
have it's that that's that caveat
right dude how weird is it that that's
true that the dem
so millennial women are like 70 democrat
that's that's pew research 68
of millennial women are democrats and
then uh
among uh men it's slightly conservative
but pretty even
yeah well that's by design so in the
late 60s the democrats decided to
to jettison the white working male from
their
efforts in terms of recruiting people
and they specifically set out a strategy
to
court the disaffected they used words
that we wouldn't use today about
homosexual people and about minority
folks and about
just all the other factions who was the
dude who ran against nixon in his
re-election
mcgovern mcgovern and he got obliterated
yeah he was that guy who
wanted to do the coalition of
progressives of like white
college-educated elites and minorities
and he got annihilated in a 49-state
landslide
is that going to happen that's that man
that that would be amazing
but i don't want to doubt it i don't
really know what's going to happen in
fact i got to admit
it's get you know get a little jittery i
mean either way
everything will be you know you said
nixon
and mcgovern is that right he also did a
49 and reagan
okay and uh i i think reagan was for
similar reasons too they tried doing a
big progressive push and regular people
that's what biden's doing so crazy but
here's the crazy thing
we're we're looking at early voting data
right and it's like right now at
nationally i think it's like four points
up democrat
what if those democrat vote republican
you know what i mean
it's probably wishful thinking to be
like oh the polls are wrong and the
democrats are actually voting for
republicans
yeah yeah no no democrats are probably
up we expected this
and republicans surprisingly are doing
really well in ohio
uh and wisconsin and michigan they're
leading in those three states
so uh i think we're actually there's a
scenario where
could you imagine if we do 269 to 269
in the electoral college it would go to
house delegations trump would win
it's not going to be this hardcore
deadlock but that would be
so on on point for 2020 you know what i
mean well i mean either way
unless it's a clear landslide neither
either direction it's gonna feel like
269 to 269
the way it's going to be drawn out i
think we all need to prepare for that
like save your adrenal system save your
dopamine surges save your stressing out
i really don't think that there's going
to be like a decisive factor on the
third although i would greatly welcome
it in our faith
we're going to have this big election
night party so
what yeah we still got and what we're
going to do is we're going to stream the
whole night
and people are going to come in and out
whoever wants to hop on the stream and
be like yo what's going on and
i'll probably be downstairs hanging out
with people i'll come up periodically
and a bunch of people do that
but i'm wondering like at what point do
we turn the stream off because it's
going to be like 4am and they're going
to be like we have no idea what happened
2 a.m 2 a.m is one night so when they
end everything no
no but there's not going to be results
because i think uh uh pennsylvania is
not doing their results until the 10th
or whatever
yeah and i found out so i have someone
who voted in colorado
and so they got their ballot back and
they're like something's wrong with your
signature
all right cool i'm glad you're checking
out my signature you can vote again on
the 12th like you can just go
in until the 12th remember you can go in
on the 12th
so you can go on the 12th and they'll
set your signature correct as
late as the 12th of november and i was
like there's no way this is gonna be
done by
well unless unless like they can map out
so a lot of people are saying and i
literally just said it
pennsylvania is not going to know their
results until the 10th or whatever
because of late ballots
but they can actually look at registered
voters
and likely voters they can model out and
be like there's literally no way
any amount of votes will change the
results of this county they always do
that yeah so that's what happens every
time exactly we see the like we you know
89
there are some places where it's like 37
precincts reporting
landslide because it's a guarantee
there's no amount of votes they could
get
with remaining precincts to win right so
we might actually just see that we might
on election night it might be
you know landslide joe biden
that's not why i was just mine i know i
tell you i thought you could cross your
fingers i said biden's dead
that'd be cool i would welcome a
landslide i would too
just to get it over with i don't want i
don't want to sit around for two weeks
not for abiding dude did you i just want
this this is
to end on the third so we can move on
yeah it's not it's it's not gonna end
men
like so the media has become addicted
to culture war every everyone has
and when you have billion dollar
corporations
that are like what do we do when the
orange man is gone
they're going to start looking for for
villains to write about
kanye yeah maybe yeah yep and
and joe rogan for sure and comedians and
what did robert wright say truth and
reconciliation commissions
dude we got to have him on the show or
no i mean
well i'll tell you what sure like i'm
willing to have anybody on well not
anybody there
so someone asked me on twitter like are
there limits and i was like yeah like
physical safety and
yeah people have to be uh relevant to
the conversation
so he is sure i have him on but he's
like truth and reconciliation so weird
yeah what they're gonna do is they're
gonna they're gonna they're gonna uh no
platform d
platform and cancel people so we all end
up with
no technology no bank accounts like oh
you know nobody wants to work with you
because you're one of those
i heard a very scary bit of speculation
that the reason that they selected
kamala harris was so that she could be
the champion
i'm sorry whatever kay harris hey harris
uh so that she could be the prosecutor
in chief of the truth and reconciliation
effort oh gosh which actually makes
pretty good sense i mean
she's not there's one thing she can do
right so they're going to like rendition
people
it's like you know why not that makes me
angry that's what makes me want to riot
not so much stuff makes me want to ride
have you you guys have all seen v for
vendetta yeah you know the scene where
creedy comes in and and knocks out
stephen fry
and then he like drags him away like it
would be fun to make like a jiff where
it's you know kamala harris has creedy
and then like
stephen fries alex jones i think it's
black bagged and like taking
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you